now I understand you submitted to
several festivals and you had to re edit
the film yeah yeah yeah it's it's tough
man when you're dealing with with so
many people in a collaboration you have
so many people that are involved in the
project right and you have so many
different desires to have it come
together and ultimately you want to work
as a team you want to like pull things
together and like what I wanted was that
everyone would be happy with the final
product and you know there's people out
there that showed themselves emotionally
physically you know there were arguments
out there and that's tough to see later
right especially in a documentary it's
not a narrative it's not something you
shot and can read it and recut and we're
going to shoot it again it happened that
it was seven days and that was what
happened and so yeah people asked to not
include things in the film and
ultimately i followed everyone's wishes
on what they didn't want in and you know
our agreements were basically like you
know if you shoot stuff out there and
ends up on the editing hard drives well
then it's going to be part of the
project there's going to be an
opportunity for you to be like oh please
don't include this and we'll probably
won't include it but that was kind of a
deal some people broke that agreement
and some people have made it very very
very very very very difficult to
actually get the film finish but you
know you do what you can and yeah it's
interesting about the film festivals I
totally thought our film would be just
perfect for for Big Sky doc fest for
full frame for true false some of these
documentary film festivals are just like
wow you know I admire the projects that
are there because there are true
documentaries and this documentary is a
frickin true documentary this this film
has no set up interviews so it's it's
purely what happened this film has no
music it's exactly what your experience
out there is and this film has no
narration there's no voiceover in the
film guiding and I think through the
editing I kind of became very touchy on
that where I watched other documentaries
a lot of different doc
where the technique is to cut to an
interview cut back to something cut back
to a celebrity narrator or a voiceover
that is like guiding you through the
experience of the documentary and that
works it's true it's tested that works
that's how to make a documentary in this
film the more I the more I got into the
editing is like well to be totally
honest to be totally truthful to what
happened don't add music on top don't
add a narration on top just have it be
exactly what happened don't have someone
else or maybe don't don't even have the
people that were involved in the project
telling you what they were feeling or
thinking just show it now that comes
down to like the you know filmmaking
thing about show not tell well when you
have enough footage you can easily show
things but when you don't have the
footage of the thing that happened it's
tough to show it but we you know we did
the best we could and yeah I was like
film festivals didn't accept the film
but we were lucky enough that one did
the amazing byron bay film festival
which is in australia accepted the film
they championed it we went there we were
a highlight of the festival we were
named as like one of the 10 or 15
projects that were like noticeable or
admire below there and we actually had
two sold-out screenings of the film so
the premiere was just like a total
highlight of this whole experience to be
like okay there's 125 people sitting
here watching this film on a big screen
which is always enjoyable and 123 of the
people there loved it and that's just a
phenomenal success to be like
appreciated by the people watching the
film and to give them the experience
because a lot of people watching the
film hadn't actually been to Burning Man
and they all felt like they had just
been through this bizarre week long
experience so when you got the word that
you had to take out certain parts did
you reconsider finishing the film at
that well I mean it was it was a few
weeks of shock actually just complete
shock I mean I was unable I couldn't
couldn't think I had just been hit with
with a pretty awful scenario to be in
especially after you know this is a
month after the film went out to the
film festival so is like you know what
do you do in that case you got to finish
something so yeah I readded it the whole
film stuff and you had releases from
everybody yeah or a majority what would
you advise another filmmaker on that in
terms of they have releases from people
and there's just someone that's
contesting the release or yeah just
coming to you on a person-to-person
level it's tough I think that's why
there's contracts that's why people sign
things that's why there's releases that
say I'm giving my footage to this thing
you know that's that's what filmmaking
is all about and I think you know
certain people have their legal
contracts all tight you know and stuff
still happens like I know I know films
that are totally done with celebrities
in them and they can't get frickin
release because there's some argument
about who owes who money I mean it
happens to freaking Lord of the Rings
right we're talking you know tens of
millions of dollars there's still an
argument there's still a problem these
things happen with the big time people
so there's going to be you know
arguments and discussions and you just
got to work it out you just gotta sort
of down hopefully the people you
collaborate with are willing to work
things out and keep agreements and stuff
like that so you said you wrestled with
it for three weeks well yeah I was just
in shock I like what do you do re-edit
the whole film the film's already been
out to film festivals like what are you
hi uh sorry I have to take the film back
here I here's another version like
there's deadlines film festivals have
deadlines so yeah it was just like what
do you do what do you do what do you do
well you have to do what you got to do
and lucky enough for us i was able to
read it the whole film and get the
approval so that's that's the other
thing burning man has to approve the the
projects so yeah we redid the approval
process and got the new version of the
film finally approved which is like who
knows because your contract with burning
man basically says they could not
approve it for any reason so you're
you're you're like crossing fingers
you're hoping you're wishing you're
trying to make it happen and we were
lucky enough that happened we got the
approval to premiere the version and and
we and Byron Bay also got the new
version they were okay with that and so
we were able to premiere the film like
it is now I mean the final cut of the
film is what we will be premiere
you